we didn't have to wait much longer for a
sonic the hedgehog sequel and now it's
finally hitting the big screen we're
getting more in this one with an even
bigger cast and better action sequences
a true sonic movie should have let's go
super sonic behind the scenes of sonic
the hedgehog 2. number one luckily for
sonic voice actor ben schwartz he didn't
have to get his hands dirty for the cgi
you have to act out what your face is
going to do you almost have to give it a
little bit more he was able to stay
behind the mic for his character and was
fitted with a face motion capture camera
to get all the best facial expressions
probably a little too close for comfort
way easier to not have james there
that's a waste of time around me
designers were really the ones who had
to put in a lot of model work to nail
down the size and look of the character
sonic wasn't the only one getting all
the love though tails and knuckles all
got their own figures we're sure they
got the same treatment as ben we are
alone we have a voice in our head and
that's directing us number two onlookers
who got a glimpse of the
behind-the-scenes action were probably a
little terrified of what was about to
happen as the crew rolled onto set they
brought real tanks and helicopters with
them we can only expect bigger
explosions and heavy artillery in this
one we all know sonic isn't a stranger
to being on the government's bad side
and can only hope they're stepping up
their game against robotnik
number three filming for the second
movie all took place in hawaii and
canada which probably made for a lot of
moving around but who wouldn't want to
film in these places the beautiful
mountain and beach regions are certainly
great for the eyes having the privilege
of filming a blockbuster in only two
locations saves time and money we're
just happy that sonic and his friends
were able to stay warm in their fur in
canada let's not get into whether or not
there was shedding involved for the
beach filming
number four while most of the makeup was
done digitally for our heroes it didn't
necessarily mean no effort was put in
during filming we now know sonic and his
group of video game characters were made
into physical models the amount of
detail that went into making them this
way was to make it easier to light and
design in post placing them at very
precise angles and heights allowed
artists to light the characters more
accurately in respect to their
environment the only non-animated
character worth mentioning on this one
is dr robotnik jim carrey sports his
iconic stash but not by his own growing
makeup artists made the long whiskers
and simply glued it to his face
number 5 for a lot of the on-screen
actors working with cgi became rather
easy for actor james marston he spent
most of his time talking to thin air the
most coveted safe covet friendly way to
uh to shoot a film luckily for james
he's no stranger to working with
animated co-stars in live-action films
and he got the opportunity to
collaborate with ben during the process
they were shooting all of my stuff first
to be sent back to ben and he would have
to kind of fill in the gaps
number six it's always nice seeing our
favorite stars pass on some love to the
crew and carrie spreads his with a brand
new car he gave one lucky crew member a
brand new chevy blazer rs that's a
pretty expensive one too valued close to
forty thousand dollars we always knew
jim was a stand-up guy to everyone he
worked with and we're not surprised by
this generous act hey if there's any
help you need on your next film sign us
up carrie
number seven due to a global pandemic it
made for quite a cumbersome process it
never really suffered as other
productions did at the time but they
still had to push back a few release
dates so once it came time for them to
finally wrap production they had the
luck of filming the last scene in hawaii
but did they take a little break after
filming a massive blockbuster picture
nope not a minute was wasted for the
post crew they went right into editing
and putting together the best sequel
they could we wouldn't judge though if
they had a pina colada or two before
flying back to the studio number eight
sonic the hedgehog was one of the most
successful video game to film
adaptations so there was no question
that they'd come out with a sequel but
this one isn't going to be your ordinary
film filmmakers wanted it to be even
bigger than before director jeff fowler
had a lot of great material to pull from
for the sequel i mean there's so much
great material to pull from sonic voice
actor ben schwartz gives his stamp of
approval and a couple details on the new
movie saying sonic has some place to
grow sonic has with the scale
number nine as with every release of a
fan favorite franchise the posters have
got to be right and this time creators
may have left a couple of the main cast
out of it the original theatrical poster
released online and fans were furious
that it didn't list two of the main
characters at the top stars tikka sumter
and colleen o'shaughnessy were left out
for unknown reasons thank goodness
they've released the poster with the
much needed corrections and this wasn't
the first time fans got the studio to
change something from the sonic movie
number 10 colleen steps back into a very
comfortable role that she made iconic
and coming back to tales was actually
very easy for her i can easily step into
those shoes this was definitely a
different experience when we saw tales
arrival at the end of the first film we
knew that a team-up was happening and
after seeing him step through the portal
in the sequel's trailer we noticed some
slight changes to his appearance the
color of his fur lightened up a bit and
it got quite the upgrade
number 11 at the soul of these films is
a beating heart of friendship fowler
used this theme to progress sonic's
adventure to new heights i think we
always work really hard on the script to
have that heart in there it was super
important for the cast and crew to build
strong relationships on set that's all
it takes to make a successful sonic
movie and with the cast on board with
this theme it made the film all the more
better when you have the heart and when
you care about what happens to your
characters a movie goes from good to
great number 12. actress tika sumter
didn't get any action in the first film
so she wanted in on some in the second i
said i want two people are active and
they listen now that she got her wish
we're excited to see where she goes in
this one it's a good thing too that
she'll be able to get some stunts in
given she was really stationary before
and she's headstrong that she doesn't
want to go back to her previous
situation first of all don't make me be
on the phone the whole movie and
pregnant or anything number 13 as all
avid video gamers obsess over are those
interesting little easter eggs it's a
great problem to have that there's so
many great easter eggs to kind of
incorporate we were graced with a little
nod to the video games when sonic and
tails fly in the signature biplane from
the original games and a film adaptation
of a video game has got to have them for
the sake of the ultimate fans this movie
is chock full of them i couldn't even
begin to list them number 14 with the
announcement of idris elba joining the
cast as knuckles he wanted to change up
the persona a bit the personal touches
that i try to bring i guess a sense of
humor anyone who knows alba's character
style knows this one's certainly a new
type of approach but he was able to find
some unique aspects of his own
personality and bring it through his
voice acting i would just bring some
oddities to him maybe this was the role
he was always meant for and we just
never realized it you know me i'm i'm
known for being hilarious number 15
carrie seems to be at home living in the
shoes of dr robotnik maybe a little too
comfortably i think robotnik is the
perfect fit for me i am a master jim can
be seen throughout his whole career
playing over the top characters so there
was no question whether he'd take on the
role once again when i get that call
i'll be there especially when it comes
to such a beloved video game villain the
eggman actor just wanted to make the
kids laugh and the adults cry with
nostalgia
i'll be in the way kids laugh when they
want a new jim carrey movie there are a
lot of factors going into the making of
this amazing sequel and with such a
star-studded cast we can be sure it's in
good hands which addition to the roster
of characters are you most excited about
let us know in the comments